avec le projet de loi C18 le
gouvernement promet de rétablir un peu
d'équilibre dans l'écosystème médiatique
canadien en forçant les géants du web à
compenser les entreprises d'information
pour l'utilisation de leur matériel une
approche qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité la semaine dernière Google a
offert un avant-goût de sa riposte en
bloquant l'accès aux nouvelles
canadiennes pour une partie de ces
utilisateurs comment le gouvernement
Trudeau voit-il ce que certains
qualifient de campagne d'intimidation
posons la question à Pablo Rodriguez le
ministre du Patrimoine du gouvernement
Trudeau responsable du projet de loi C18
puis Rodriguez merci d'être là est-ce
que c'est de l'intimidation absolument
que clairement avec un soupçon
d'arrogance je dirais bloquer l'accès
aux nouvelles c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave à mon avis vous
savez il y a 67% des Canadiens qui vont
chercher les nouvelles en ligne on les
lire en ligne et de ce montant là 95 13%
des gens passent par Google donc il
s'agit ici d'un quasi monopole de la
part de Google qui étudie cette potion
là de force pour essayer d'intimider le
gouvernement et les Canadiens mais vous
avez averti en même temps les géants du
Web vous avez dit que c'est une
possibilité Facebook mettant le fait en
Australie quand le gouvernement
australien est allé dans la même
direction que vous ouais mais c'est pas
parce qu'ils disent qu'on peut faire ça
que c'est correct de le faire c'est
vraiment prendre les Canadiens un hôtel
vous savez la situation est critique sur
le plan des médias
460 salles de nouvelles ou un peu plus
ont fermé leur porte au cours des
dernières années des grandes des radios
des télévisions des journaux on vient de
voir récemment il y a des coupures chez
TVA il y a un autre chez globalmous ça
touche tout le monde pourquoi parce que
du 10 milliards de dollars que de la
totalité des fonds qui sont dépensés en
publicité en ligne et notre 80% qui s'en
va à deux compagnies Google et Facebook
ce qui a femme le reste de secteur de
l'industrie et ça ça fait en sorte qu'il
disparaissent graduellement et c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie je
dirais que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
Google Google disait cette semaine que
le modèle que vous avez proposé dans ces
18 il ouvre la porte à la
dissémination de davantage de
désinformation sur le web vous dites
quoi ça pas du tout absolument pas vous
savez le projet de loi c'est 18 il est
très simple tout d'abord le premier
principe moi je vais être le plus loin
possible je vais tenir les cartes de là
je ne veux pas avoir à prendre de
décision sur qui reçoit de l'argent ou
qui bénéficie de quoi que ce soit tout
ce qu'on fait le gouvernement c'est
qu'on met c'est comme si on mettait une
table dans le milieu et on demande une
plateforme en position dominante pour
l'instant Google de Facebook de
s'asseoir et de négocier avec les
différents médias canadiens les grands
les petits ainsi de suite et qu'ils
arrivent à une entente ou c'est géant du
web là vont compenser de façon juste le
travail qui se fait par des journalistes
professionnels à travers le pays si
arrive pas à une entente à ce moment-là
ils savons à un arbitrage final ou des
arbitres indépendants vont trancher d'un
côté ou de l'autre c'est tout c'est tout
ce que ça représente mais vous savez
ce que vous faites vous par exemple
aujourd'hui ce qui est fait votre équipe
autour de vous ce que font les salles de
nouvelles à travers le CADA ça une
valeur et ces plateformes-là utilisent
ça à être diffuseur de façon gratuite
sans rémunérer qui que ce soit alors il
y a une profonde injustice disparition
de nos médias neutre indépendant non
partisan affaiblissement de la
démocratie ça donnerait quoi pour le
commun il est mortel ça ferait quoi
comme différence imaginons proche de loi
est adopté les négociations ont lieu et
un transfert d'argent dans votre tête là
ça donne quoi comme revenu
supplémentaire aux organisations
d'information canadiennes puisqu'à
change concrètement sur le terrain ben
ça change énormément de choses tout
d'abord le montant final difficile à
connaître pour l'instant parce que ça va
dépendre des accords justement négociés
ou au gouvernement ne participe pas donc
les accords qui seraient conclus en gogo
Facebook et le milieu des médias au
Canada et je fais une parenthèse mais ça
va aussi favoriser les petits médias
puisqu'on change des éléments de la loi
qui est Industrie Canada pour permettre
les négociation collective donc vous
permettre à plein de petits médias à
travers le Cadhoc au Québec ou ailleurs
de négocier conjointement face ou à ces
gens que son facebook et Google et
qu'est-ce que et qu'est-ce que ça change
ben c'est de l'argent que ça va aux
salles de nouvelles parce que nous dans
le projet de loi est-ce que ce que l'on
a mis dans cette s’assurer que l'argent
qui transféré aille pour la création de
contenu de nouvelles et non pas enrichir
les poches de rouleau des propriétaires
de ces médias
est-ce que vous avez qualifié tout à
l'heure de campagne de d'intimidation
avec un soupçon d'arrogance de la part
de Google ça ne vous fera pas reculer
cette dans le processus non absolument
pas non absolument pas
l'immédiat joue un rôle fondamental au
sein de notre démocratie ici dans les
autres grandes démocraties et ces médias
là neutrent non partisans indépendant
disparaissent graduellement alors notre
démocratie est pas en train de se
renforcer elle est en train de
s'affaiblir ce qui laisse beaucoup plus
de place à des fausses nouvelles à la
désinformation et ça ça vient affaiblir
également le tissu social donc il faut
renforcer ces médias indépendants là
quand c'est cama avoir ce projet de
vente adopter vous parlez de médias
beaucoup vous parlez des informations
est-ce que la définition de médias dans
le projet de loi est suffisamment clair
d'après vous parce qu'il y en a qui
disent qu'elle est pour être plus clair
que ça non ce sont des critères qui sont
indépendants encore une fois je ne
voulais pas moi comme une liste définir
qui est un média ou qui ne l'était pas
donc il y a un projet similaire en
Australie qui a vu le jour dans lequel
le rôle à mon avis le rôle du ministre
des différents ministres c'est beaucoup
trop important et on a changé ça au
Canada pour faire en sorte que ce soit
des critères n'est pas là par exemple
avoir le minimum de deux journalistes
avoir des nouvelles générales et non pas
je sais pas moi c'est spécialisé sur
quelque chose de très spécifique le
camping par exemple on aime bien le
camping mais il faut que ça soit des
nouvelles d'intérêts publics alors il y
a l'ensemble de règles et de définition
qui viennent clarifier ce que le
sont les médias journalistes est-ce que
est-ce que dans votre tête ce projet de
loi-là il est adopté avant l'été oh je
l'espère de tout cas vous savez on a
l'appui du évidemment du gouvernement
libéral mais du Bloc québécois du
Nouveau Parti démocratique donc une très
vaste majorité de la chambre
probablement sur on compte là peut-être
les deux tiers de la chambre un autre
projet là vous avez parrainé ces projets
de l'océan sur la radio Diffusion qui
fera en sorte en fait que on irait
chercher on imposerait certaines règles
en termes de contenu au géant comme
Netflix comme YouTube comme Disney au
Canada ce projet de loi là a été adopté
aux communes et passer au Sénat et
revenus avec un certain nombre
d'amendements ça vous plait
quand vous êtes de contenu on leur dit
pas quoi produire on dit simplement que
on va avoir plus de contenu de chez nous
ce qu'on demande à fait le prochain loi
est très simple on demande où streamers
Netflix et Amazon Prime les disney quand
même beaucoup là moi je m'aime je suis
abonné à paquet d'entre eux on leur
demande simplement de contribuer à la
production de plus de musique de chez
nous de plus de contenu télévision et de
cinéma de chez nous que ça soit du
contenu québécois ou d'ailleurs dans les
deux langues officielles donc il va
beaucoup plus de contenu francophone en
français et je vous dirais que je parle
régulièrement avec ces gens-là ils ont
compris que quand on était rendu là
comme société et ils embarquent
là-dedans donc maintenant le prochaine
loi est revenu de Sénat on doit avoir un
débat ensemble et le retourner par la
suite au Sénat idéalement pour sanction
royale encore une fois le projet
bénéficie de l'appui d'une du Bloc
québécois j'espère qu'on pourra aller de
l'avant très rapidement Mathieu Lacombe
le ministre de la Culture au Québec qui
disait cette semaine qu'il a envisageait
peut-être de même légiférer du côté
québécois pour pour imposer certaines
obligations même plateformes vous en
pensez quoi ben je discute souvent avec
Monsieur Lacom on s'entend extrêmement
bien c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie
énormément suite à personnel également
je ne vois pas le besoin je pense que
c'est 11 fait la job comme on dit mais
s'ils croient qu'il y a des certains
éléments qui doivent être fait au niveau
du Québec moi j'en vois pas je vois pas
le problème mais j'en vois pas la
nécessité si c'est 11 passes tel quel à
ce moment-là on vient combler les
besoins du milieu de la musique du
cinéma de la télévision ainsi de suite
et séance est adopté cette adoptique
après vous c'est ça à force de loi quand
le plus vite possible on retourne
bientôt j'espère dans les prochaines
semaines ministre du Patrimoine merci
d'avoir été des nôtres c'est moi qui
vous remercie au revoir